the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
we're talking about generalized linear
models and in generalized linear models
we generalized linear models in two ways
the first one is to allow for different
distributions for the response variables
and the distributions that we wanted was
the exponential family and this is a
family that can be generalized over
random variables that if I don't say RQ
in general with parameters in RK but
we're gonna focus in a very specific
case where this is when R is equal why
is a real-valued response variable which
is the one you're used to when you're
doing linear regression and the
parameters theta also lives in R and so
we're gonna talk about the canonical
case so that's the canonical exponential
family where you have a density of theta
of X which is of the form exponential
minus sorry exponential plus and then we
have Y which interact with theta only by
taking a product then there's a term
that depends only on theta some
dispersion parameter Phi and then we
have some normalization factor let's
call it C of Y Phi so it only depends so
I really should not matter too much so
it's su of Wi-Fi and that's really just
a normalization factor and here we said
that we're gonna assume that Phi is
known okay I just I have no idea what I
write that although if you guys can read
I don't know what chocolate has been
used today but I just can't see it
that's not my fault all right so we're
gonna assume that Phi is known and so we
saw that you know several distributions
that we know well including the Gauss
for example belong to this family and
there's other ones the chess place oh
sorry
quest someone Burnley so if the PMF has
this form if you have a discrete random
variable this is also valid and the
reason why we introduced this family is
because they're gonna be some property
so we know that this thing here this
function B of theta is essentially what
completely characterizes your
distribution right so if Phi is fixed we
know that the interaction is the form
this form and this really just comes
from the fact that we want the function
to integrate to one so this B here in
the canonical form encodes everything we
want to know if I tell you what B of
theta is and of course I tell you what's
Phi is but let's say for a second that
Phi is equal to one if I tell you this B
of theta you know exactly what
distribution I'm talking about so it
should encode everything that's you know
specific to this distribution such as me
invariants all the moments that you
would want and we'll see how we can
compute from this thing the mean and the
variance for example so today we're
gonna talk about likelihood and we're
gonna start with the likelihood function
or the log likelihood for one
observation from this we're gonna do
some computations and then we'll move on
to the actual log likelihood based on n
independent observations and here as we
will see the observations are not going
to be identically distributed because
we're gonna want each of them I mean
conditionally on X to have a different
to be a different function of X okay to
where theta is just a different function
of X for each of the observations all
right so remember the log likelihood and
this is for one observation it's just
the log of the density right and we have
this identity that I mentioned at the
end of the class on Tuesday and this
identity is just that the expectation of
the derivative of this guy with respect
to theta is equal to zero so let's see
why so if I take the derivative with
respect to theta of log F theta of X
what I get is the derivative with
respect to theta of f theta of X divided
by F theta of X
right now if I take the expectation of
this guy with respect to this data as
well what I get is that this thing what
is the expectation well it's just the
integral against F theta or if I'm in a
discrete case I just have the sum
against F theta right if it's a PMF just
the distribution the definition of right
expectation of X is either the integral
Y let's say of H of X is the integral of
H of X at theta of X if this is discrete
or is just the sum of H of X F theta of
X if X is discrete so if it continues
you put this you know sweet soft sum and
if it's this guy it's the same thing
right so I'm just gonna illustrate the
case when it's continuous so this is
what well this is the integral of
partial derivative with respect to theta
of f theta of X divided by F theta of X
prime F theta of X DX and now this F
theta is canceled so I'm actually left
with the integral of the derivative
which I'm going to write as the
derivative of the integral but F theta
being being sorry F theta being density
for any value of theta I can take this
is the function as a function of theta
well actually as a function of theta
this function is constantly equal to 1
right for any theta I take it takes
value 1 so this is constantly equal to 1
I put 3 bars to say that for any value
of theta this is 1 which actually tells
me that the derivative is equal to 0 ok
yes
that that's the definition of the
expectation I'm sorry no that's just the
definition of the derivative of the log
of a function log of f prime is f prime
over F right that's a log yeah just by
elimination I'm sorry yeah and then you
do good because that's probably how my
mind's processes and so I'm like yeah
I'll here's enough information okay
everybody's good with this so you know
that was convenient so it just said that
the expectation of the derivative of the
log likelihood is equal to zero that's
going to be our first identity let's
move on to the second identity using
exactly the same trick which is let's
hope that at some point we have the
integral of this function that's
constantly equal to one as a function of
theta and then should show that it use
the fact that it's derivative is equal
to zero so if I start taking the second
derivative of the log of f of theta so
what is this well it's the second
derivative of it's the derivative of
this guy here so I'm gonna go straight
to it so it's second derivative of F
theta of x times F theta of X minus
second derivative the first derivative
of F theta of x times first derivative
of F theta of X here is some super
important stuff not kidding and so you
can still see that guy over there
alright so it's just the square and then
I divided by F theta of x squared okay
so here I have the second derivative
times F itself and here have the product
of the first derivative itself with
itself right so that's the square so now
I'm going to integrate this guy so if I
take the expectation of this thing here
what I get is the integral so here the
only thing that's going to happen when
I'm going to take my integral is that
this one of those squares is going to
cancel against F theta right so I'm
gonna get the second derivative minus
the second derivative squared and then
I'm divided by F theta I know that this
thing is equal to zero okay now one of
this guy here sorry why do I have yeah
so I have this guy here so this guy here
is gonna cancel right so this is what
this is equal to the integral of the
partial so the second derivative of F
theta of X right because those two guys
cancel minus the integral of the second
derivative okay and this is telling me
what it's telling me that
[Music]
yeah I'm losing one because they have
some weird consequences thank you okay
so this is actually yeah okay because
now this is not well this is still
positive so I know this thing I want to
see that this thing is actually equal to
zero but then it gives me some weird
things which are that I have the
integral of a positive function which is
equal to zero
yeah that's what I'm thinking of doing
but I'm gonna get zero for this entire
integral which means that I have the
integral of a positive function which is
equal to zero which means that this
function is equal to zero which sounds a
little bad basically tells me that this
function f theta is linear so I went a
little too far I believe because I only
want to prove that the expectation of
the second derivative
I want to show that the expectation of
this I mean is that true actually that
man yes so I want to pull this out and
so let's see if I keep rolling with this
I'm gonna get that well no because the
fact that it's divided by F theta means
that indeed the second derivative is
equal to zero so I cannot do this here
okay
maybe that's correct
okay but let's write it like this so
when you write so this is what this is
the expectation of the the partial with
respect to theta of f theta of x divided
by F theta of x squared right and this
is the exactly the derivative of F of
the log right so that's indeed this
thing is equal to the expectation of
respect to theta of the partial of L
well of log of theta divided by partial
theta alright so this is one of the guys
that I want squared so this is one of
the guys that I want and this is
actually equal so this will be equal to
the expectation
oh yeah very right so this term should
be equal to zero if so yeah I wanted
this was not zero you're absolutely
right so I something I got confused
because I thought putting this equal to
zero would mean that this is zero but
this thing is not equal to zero so this
thing you're right I take the same trick
as before and this is actually equal to
zero which means that now I have what's
on the left hand side which is equal to
what's on the right hand side and if I
recap I get that etheta
of the second derivative of the log of F
theta is equal to minus because I had a
minus sign here to the expectation with
respect to theta log of F theta divided
by squared okay thank you for being on
the on watch when I'm falling apart all
right so this is exactly what you have
here except that both terms have been
put on the same side all right so those
things are gonna be useful to us so
maybe we should write them somewhere
here and then we have that the
expectation of the second derivative of
the log is equal to minus this
expectation of the square of the first
derivative okay and this is indeed my
Fisher information this is just telling
me what is the second derivative of my
log likelihood at data right so
everything is with respect to theta when
I take these expectations and so it
tells me that the expectation of the log
likely of the of the second derivative
at least first of all what it's telling
is that it's concave right because the
second derivative of this thing which is
the second derivative of the KL
divergence is actually minus something
which is must be non-negative and so
it's telling you that it's
here at this Maxim okay
and in particular it's also telling me
that it has to be strictly positive
unless the derivative of F is equal to 0
so if unless F is constant then I don't
have I'm not get it's not gonna change
all right do you have a question so now
let's use this so what does my log
likelihood looked like when I actually
computed for this canonical exponential
family right I mean we have this
exponential function so taking the log
should make my life much easier and
indeed it does so if I look at the
canonical what I have is that the log of
f theta of X well it's equal simply to Y
theta minus V of theta divided by Phi
plus in this function that only depends
that does not depend on theta okay so
let's see what this tells me what do
let's just plug in those equalities in
there right I mean I can take the
derivative of the right hand side and
just say that an expectation is equal to
0
so if I start looking at the derivative
this is equal to what well here I'm
gonna pick up only Y so this is a
function of Y I'm gonna pick only
alright I was talking about likelihood
so I actually need to put the random
variable here so I get Y minus the
derivative of B of theta since it's only
a function of theta I'm just gonna write
B prime is that okay rather than having
the partial with respect to theta then
this is a constant this does not depend
on theta so it goes away okay so if I
start taking the expectation of this guy
I get the expectation of this guy which
is the expectation of Y
- well this does not depend on why so
it's just itself B prime of theta and
the whole thing is divided by Phi but
from my first equality over there I know
that this thing is actually equal to
zero right we just proved that so in
particular it means that since Phi is
nonzero it means that this guy must be
equal to this guy or Phi is not infinity
say and so that implies that the
expectation with respect to theta Y is
equal to B prime of theta I'm sorry
you're not registered in this class I'm
gonna have to ask you to leave I'm not
kidding you are well I've never seen you
here I mean I saw you for the first
lecture okay all right so e theta of Y
is equal to B prime of theta everybody
agrees with that so this is actually
nice because if I tell you okay I told
you if I give you a financial family the
only thing I really need to tell you is
what B theta is and if I give you B of
theta then you know computing a
derivative is actually much easier than
having to integrate Y against the
density itself I mean you could really
have fun and try to compute this which
you would be able to do right and then
there's the plus C of Y 5 bla bla bla dy
and that's the way you would actually
compute this thing but that would be
that would be really sorry that's this
guy's here that would be painful right I
don't know what this normalization looks
like so I would have to also explicit
that so I can actually compute this
thing and you know just the same way if
you want to compute the expectation of a
Gaussian ok the expectation of a
Gaussian is not the most difficult one
but you know even if you compute the
expectation of a Poisson you start to
have to work in a little bit there's a
few things that you have to work through
here I'm just telling you all you have
to know is what B of theta is and then
you can just take the derivative let's
see what the second equality is gonna
give us
okay so what is the second equality it's
telling me that if I look at the second
derivative and and then I took it I take
its expectation I'm gonna have something
which is equal to negative this guy
squared we've already computed sorry
that that was the log right we've
already computed this this first
derivative of the likelihood right it's
just the expectation of the square of
this thing here
all right so expectation of the
derivative with respect to theta of log
F theta of x divided by partial theta
square this is equal to the expectation
of the square of Y minus B theta divided
by Phi squared right a B prime theta
Square and okay and so if I start
computing what is this thing well this
we just agreed that this was what the
expectation of theta right so that's
just the expectation I'm sorry the
expectation of Y which is computed here
yeah that's b-prime there's a derivative
here okay so now this is what how this
is simply anyone
I'm sorry variance of Y but there's the
scaling by Phi squared right okay so
that's so this is negative of the right
hand side of our inequality and now I
just have to take one more derivative to
this guy right so if now if I look at
and if I look at the left hand side now
I have that the partial derivative the
second derivative of log of F theta of Y
divided by partial of theta squared so
this thing is equal to well now I'm not
left with much the y part is gonna go
away and I'm left only with the second
derivative of theta a minus the second
derivative theta divided by Phi okay so
if I take expectation well it just
doesn't change this is deterministic so
now what I've established is that this
guy is equal to negative this guy so
those two things are the signs are gonna
go away and so this implies that the
variance of Y is equal to B prime prime
theta and then I have a five square in
denominator that cancels only one of the
five in the denominator that cancels
only one of the five squares so it's
time five so now I have that my second
derivative since I know Phi is
completely determined determining the
variance all right and so basically
that's what B that's why B is called the
cumulant generating function is not
generating moments but cumulants but
cumulants in this case correspond
basically to the moment so at least for
the first two if I start going fat
farther I'm not gonna have I'm going to
have more combinations of the
expectation of Y 3 y 2 and Y itself okay
so but you know as we know those are the
ones that
they're usually the most useful at least
if we're interested in asymptotic
performance the central limit theorem
tells us that all that matters are the
first two moments and then the rest is
just gonna go and say well it doesn't
matter it's all going to normal anyway
so let's go to a person for example
right so if I had a Poisson distribution
alright so this is a discrete
distribution and what I know is that so
f let me call mu the parameter of y this
is okay so it's mu to the Y divided by y
factorial exponential minus mu okay so
mu is usually called lambda and Y is
usually called X so it takes me a little
bit of time but usually slam that to the
x over factor or X exponential minus
lambda this thing clearly since this is
just the series expansion of the
exponential when I sum those things from
zero to infinity this thing sums to 1
but then if I wanted to start
understanding what the expectation of
this thing is right so if I want to
understand the expectations with respect
to MU of Y then I would have to compute
the sum from k equals 0
or let's say ya from k equals 0 to
infinity of Y times mu sort of K times
mu to the K over factorial K exponential
minus mu which means that I would
essentially have to take the derivative
okay that I would have to take the
derivative of my series in the end so
you know I can do this this is a
standard exercise you've probably done
it when you took probability but let's
see if we can actually just read it off
from the first derivative of B so to do
that we need to write this in the form
of an exponential where there's one
parameter that captures mu that
interacts with y just doing this
parameter times y and then something
that depends only on Y and then
think that depends only on sorry it
simply depends only on you that's the
important one that certain BRB and then
there's gonna be something that depends
only on Y okay so let's write this and
check that this F new indeed belongs to
this canonical exponential family so I
definitely have an exponential that
comes from this guy so I have minus mu
and then this thing is gonna give me
what is gonna give me plus y a log mu
and then I'm gonna have minus log of y
factor all right
okay so clearly I have a term that
depends only on you a terms that depend
only on Y and I have a product of Y and
something that depends on me if I want
to be canonical I must have this to be
exactly the parameters theta itself okay
so I'm gonna call this guy theta
okay so theta is log mu which means that
mu is equal to e to the theta and so
wherever I see new I'm gonna replace it
by e to the theta because my new
parameter now is theta so this is what
this is equal to exponential Y times
theta and then I'm gonna have minus y of
theta and then who cares something that
depends only on new so this is my C of Y
and Phi is equal to 1 in this case so
that's all I care about so let me pop in
let's let's use it right okay so this is
my canonical exponential family Y
interact with theta exactly like this
and then I have this function so this
function here must be B of theta right
so from this function exponential theta
I'm supposed to be able to read what the
mean is
so because since in this course I always
know what the dispersion is I can
actually always absorb it into theta for
one but here it's really of the form y
times something divided by one right I
mean I could if it was like log of nu
divided by five that would be the
question of whether I want to call Phi
five my dispersion or if I want to just
like have it in there but if I know
so usually so okay this makes no
difference in practice but the real
thing is when you it's never gonna
happen that this thing this dudes
version is gonna be an exact number if
it's an actual numerical number this
just means that this number should be
absorbed in the definition of theta but
if it's something that is called Sigma
say and I say and I will assume that
Sigma is known then it's probably
preferable to keep it in the dispersion
so you can see that there's this
parameter here that you can essentially
play with okay that it doesn't make any
difference when you know Phi okay so now
what I have so okay so if I look at the
expectation of some Y so now I'm gonna
have Y which follows my Poisson you I'm
gonna take I'm gonna look at the
expectation and I know that the
expectation is D prime of theta right
agree that's what I just erased
I think agree with this the derivative
all right so what is this well it's the
derivative of e to the theta which is e
to the theta which is new so my choice
parameterize by its mean I can also
compute the variance which is equal to
minus the second derivative of is it ya
know it's equal to the second derivative
dispersion is equal to one again if I
took fire elsewhere I would see it I
would see it here as well right so if I
just absorb Phi here I would see it
divided here so it would not make any
difference and what is the second
derivative of the exponential I still
the exponential but still like wall to
mute okay so that certainly makes our
life easier
just one quick remark here's here's the
B function I I giving you a problem can
the be function of some this function we
can it ever be equal to log of theta
who says yes who says no why
yeah all right so what I've learned from
this I sort of completely analytic right
so we just took derivatives and this
thing just happened right this thing
actually allowed us to relate the second
derivative of B to the variance and one
thing that we know about a variance is
that this is non-negative and in
particular it's always positive right I
mean if I give you an exponent a
canonical exponential family that has
zero variance trust me you will see it
right I mean that means that this thing
is not going to look like something
that's finite it means it's gonna have a
point mass it's gonna take value
infinity at one point so this will
basically never happen the other thing
is actually strictly positive which
means that this thing is always like
strictly concave it means that the
second derivative of this function B has
to be strictly positive and so that the
function is convex okay so this is
concave so this is definitely not
working I need to have something that
looks like this when I talk about my B
okay so it's data squared we'll see a
bunch of exponential theta you know
there's a bunch of them but if you start
writing something and you find B you
know try to think of the plot of B in
your mind and you find that B looks like
it's gonna be concave you're being
you've made a sign mystic somewhere
alright so we've done a pretty big
parenthesis to try to characterize what
the distribution of Y was gonna be right
we wanted to extend from say Gaussian to
something else and but when we're doing
regression which means the generalized
linear models we are not interested in
the distribution of Y but really the
conditional distribution of Y given X so
I need now to sort of couple those back
together all right so what I know is
that this same you in this case which is
the expectation what I want to say is
that the conditional expectation of Y
given mu sorry the conditional
expectation of Y given X this is some u
of X right and when we did linear models
we said well this thing was some x
transpose beta for linear models
and the whole premise of this chapter is
to say well this might make no sense
because X transpose beta can take the
entire range of real values whereas this
mu can take only a partial range so even
if you actually focus on the on the
Poisson for example we know that the
expectation of a Poisson has to be a
non-negative number actually a positive
number as soon as you have a little bit
of variance right it's mu itself mu is a
positive number and so it's not gonna
make any sense to assume that mu of X is
equal to X transpose beta because you
might find some excess for which this
value ends up being negative and so
we're gonna need what we call the link
function that relates that transforms
new maps it onto the real line so that
you can now express it of the form X
transpose beta all right so we're gonna
take not this but we're going to assume
that G of mu of X is now equal to X
transpose beta and that's the
generalized linear models right okay so
as I said it's kind of weird to
transform X transpose beta mu to make it
take the real line it feels like this to
me it feels a bit more natural to take X
transpose beta and make it fit to the
particular distribution that I want and
so I'm gonna want to talk about g and g
inverse at the same time so i'm gonna
actually take always G so G is my link
function and I'm gonna want G to be
continuously differentiable
okay let's say that it has a derivative
and it's derivative is is continuous and
I'm gonna want G to be strictly
increasing okay
and that actually implies that G inverse
exists actually that's not true what I'm
also going to want is that G of mu spans
okay how do I do this okay so I want the
G as I arrange for all possible values
of MU whether they're all positive
values or whether they're values that
are limited between the interval 0 1 I
want those to span the entire real line
so that when I want to talk about G
inverse is defined over the entire real
line I know where I started okay so this
implies that G inverse exists what else
does it imply about universe
so for a function to be invertible on I
only need for it to be strictly monotone
right I don't need it to be strictly
increasing so in particular the fact
that I picked increasing implies that
this guy is actually increasing okay
that's the image okay so this is my link
function and this slide is just telling
me I want my function to be invertible
so I can talk about universe I'm gonna
switch between the two so what like
functions am I gonna get right so for
linear models we just said there's no
link function which is the same as
saying that the link function is
identity which certainly satisfies all
these conditions it's invertible it has
all these nice properties but you know
might as well not talk about it for
personal data when we assume that the
conditional distribution of Y given X is
Poisson and then mu as I just said is
required to be positive so I need a G
that goes from the interval 0 infinity
to the entire real line
I need a function that starts from 1 and
then just you know takes not only the
the positive values are split between
positive and negative values and here
for example I could take the log link
right so the log is defined on this
entire interval and as I range from 0 to
plus infinity the log is ranging from
negative infinity to plus infinity right
so you know you can probably think of
other functions that do that like two
times log that's another one all right
but there's many other you can think of
and but let's see the log is one of them
that you might want to think about
then there's we'll see that this is
actually I mean it is a natural and in
the sense that it's one of the first
function we can think of it we'll see
also that it has another canonical
property that makes it a natural choice
the other one is the other example where
we had a even stronger conditional what
you could beam you could only be a
number between 0 and 1 that was the
probability of success of a coin flip
right
probably a success of a Bernoulli random
variable and now I need G to map 0 1 2
the entire real line and so here are a
bunch of things that you can come up
with because you know now you start to
have maybe I mean you know I claim I
will soon claim that this one log of mu
divided by 1 minus mu is the most
natural one but maybe you know if you
have never thought of this that might
not be the most the first function you
would come up with right
you mentioned trigonometric functions
for example so you know maybe you can
come up with something that like you
know comes from a hyper hyperbolic
trigonometric or something so what does
this function do well we'll see a
picture but this function does map the
interval 0 1 to the entire real line we
also discussed the fact that if we think
reciprocally
well a function what I want if I want to
think about G inverse I want a function
that map's the entire real line into the
unit interval and as we said if I'm not
very creative statistician or Prabha
list I can just pick my favorites
continuous strictly increasing
cumulative distribution function which
as we know will arise as soon as they
have a density that has support on the
entire real line right if I have support
everywhere then it means that my by
meaning that the density is strictly
positive everywhere that it means that
my community distribution function has
to be strictly increasing and of course
it has to go from 0 to 1 because that's
just nature of those things and so for
example I can take the Gaussian that's
one such function but I could also take
you know the double exponential that
looks like an exponential on one end and
then an exponential on the other end and
[Music]
basically if you take something which is
called which if you take capital Phi
which is the Gaussian standard Gaussian
cumulative distribution function it does
work for you and you can take its
inverse and in this case we don't talk
about so this guy is called log it or
logit and this guy is called Prabhat and
you see it usually every time you have a
package on generalized in your models
you're trying to implement you have this
choice and for what's called logistic
regression so it's kind of funny that
it's called logistic regression but you
can actually use the
Prabhat link which in this case is get I
guess it's called probably regression
but those things are essentially
equivalent and it's really a matter of
taste
okay maybe of community some communities
might prefer one or the other
we'll see that again as I claim before
the logistic one the look at one is has
a slightly more compelling argument for
its reason to exist I guess this one the
compelling argument is that is involved
the central the standard Gaussian which
of course is something that should show
up everywhere and then you can think
about crazy stuff okay something that
even even crazy gets a name come live a
complimentary log log which is the log
of minus log one - okay you know why not
[Music]
so I guess you can iterate that thing
and you can just do put a 1 log 1 minus
in front of this thing it's still gonna
go all right so that's not true I have
to put a minus and take another no
that's not true
ok so ok so you can think of whatever
you want but now you can actually so
I'll show so I claim that the legit link
is the natural choice so here's a
picture I should have actually plotted
the other one so we can actually compare
it to be fair I don't even remember how
it would actually fit in those in those
two function so the blue one which is
this one for those of you who don't see
the difference to blue and red sorry
about that
so this is the so the blue one is the
logistic one so that's okay so this guy
is the function that does e to the x
over 1 plus e to the X as you can see
this is a function that's supposed to
map the entire real line into the
interval 0 1 ok so that's supposed to be
the inverse of your function and I claim
that this is the inverse of the logistic
of the locate function and the blue one
well this is the Gaussian CDF so you
know it's clearly the inverse of the
inverse of the Gaussian CDF and that's
the red one that's the one that goes
here so one of the thing that I would
guess that the complementary log log is
something that's probably going above
here and for which the slope is actually
even
Flattr as you cross zero okay so okay so
of course this is not our link functions
these are the inverse of our link
function so what do they look like when
I actually basically flipped my my thing
like this so this is what I see okay and
so I can see that in blue this is my
logistic link so I have it crosses zero
with a slightly faster rate remember or
hope if we could use the identity that
would be very nice to us right we would
just want to take the identity the
problem is that if I started you know
having the identity that goes here it's
gonna start being a problem and this is
the the Prabhat link the Phi inverse
that you see here it's a little flatter
I mean you can check right what you can
compute the derivative at zero of those
guys and you will see that what is the
derivative of the so log so I'm taking
the derivative of log of x over 1 minus
X so it's 1 over X minus 1 over X no
minus 1 over 1/2 1 minus X ok so if I
look at 0.5 actually sorry this is the
interval 0 1 so I'm interested in the
slope at 0.5 so no yes plus thank you so
at 0.5 what I get is 2 plus 2 yeah okay
so that's okay so that's the slope that
we get and if you compute for the
derivative what is the derivative of Phi
inverse well it's a little Phi of X
divided by little Phi of capital Phi
inverse of X so little Phi at at 1/2 I
don't know yeah I guess I can probably
compute the derivative of the capital
Phi at 0 which is
to be just 1 over square root 2 pi and
then just say well the slope has to be
you know 1 over there
ok so you know it's crew 2 pi
ok so that's just a comparison but again
so far we do not have any reason to
prefer one to the other and so now I'm
gonna start giving you some reasons to
prefer one to the other and one of those
two and actually for each canonical
family there is something which is
called the canonical link and what you
don't have any other reasons to choose
anything else why not choose the
canonical one and the canonical link is
the one that says ok what I want is G to
map mu onto the real line right and but
mu is not the parameter of my canonical
family right I mean it just so here for
example mu is e of theta but the
canonical parameter is theta and the
parameter of a canonical exponential
family is something that lives in the
entire rail line right it was defined
for all Thetas and so in particular I
can just assume I can just take theta to
be the one that's X transpose beta and
so in particular I'm just gonna try to
find the link that just says ok when I
take G of MU I'm gonna map so that's
what's gonna be right so I know that G
of mu is gonna be equal to X beta and
now what I'm gonna say say okay let's
just take the G that makes this guy
equal to theta so that the sis data
actually model like X transpose beta
feels pretty canonical right I mean what
else what other central easy choice
would you take this was pretty easy
there's is a natural parameter for this
canonical family and it takes value on
the entire real line I have a function
that map's mu onto the entire real line
so let's just map it to the actual
parameter ok so now what I claim ok why
do I have this well we've already
figured that out the canonical link
function is strictly increasing okay I'm
sorry
so I said that so now I want this
so I want mu G of mu to be equal to
theta which is equivalent to saying that
I want mu to be equal to G inverse of
theta but we know that mu is what D
prime of theta so that means that B
prime is the same function as G inverse
and I claim that this is actually giving
me indeed a function that has the
properties that I want because before I
said just pick any function that has
these properties and now I'm giving you
a very hard rule to pick this that you
need still to check that it satisfies
those condition in particular that it's
increasing and invertible and so for
this to be increasing an invertible
strictly increasing and invertible
really what i need is that the inverse
is strictly increasing and invertible
which is the case here because b prime
as we said well b prime is the
derivative of a strictly convex function
a strictly convex function has the
second derivative the strictly positive
we just figured it out using the fact
that the variance was strictly positive
and if Phi is strictly positive then
this thing has to be a strictly positive
so if B prime prime is strictly positive
this is the derivative of a function
called B prime if your derivative is
strictly positive you are strictly
increasing and so we know that B prime
is indeed strictly increasing and what I
need also to check well I guess this is
already checked in its own because B
prime is actually mapping all of our
into the possible values I mean when
theta ranges on the entire real line
then B prime ranges in the entire
interval of the mean values that it can
take right and so now I have this thing
that's completely defined B prime
inverse is a valid link and it's called
the canonical link
okay so again if I give you an
exponential family which is another way
of saying you I give you a convex
function B which you know gives you some
exponential family then if you just take
B prime inverse this gives you the
Associated canonical link for this
canonical exponential family alright so
let's see why
so okay clearly there's an advantage of
doing this which is I don't have to
actually think about which one to pick
if I don't want to think about it but
there's other advantages that come to it
and we'll see that in the representation
there's basically going to be some nice
cancellations that show up so before we
go there let's just compute the
canonical link for the Bernoulli
distribution alright so remember the
Bernoulli distribution has a PMF which
is part of the canonical exponential
family all right so the PMF of the
Bernoulli is f theta of X is okay so let
me just write it like this so it's P to
the x1 so P to the Y let's say 1 minus P
to be 1 minus y which I will write as
exponential Y log P plus 1 minus y log 1
minus P ok we've done that last time
now I'm gonna group my terms and Y to
see how Y interacts with this parameter
P and what I'm getting is Y which is x
log P divided by 1 minus P and then the
only term that remains is log 1 minus P
okay now I want this to be a canonical
exponential family which means that I
just need to call this guy so it is part
of the exponential family can read that
if I wanted to be canonical this guy
must be theta itself okay so I have that
theta is equal to log P 1 minus P if I
invert this thing it tells
me that P is e to the theta divided by 1
plus e to the theta right that's just
inverting this function and so that
means that this thing is actually so in
particular it means that log 1 minus P
is equal to log 1 minus this thing so
the exponential Thetas go away so and
the numerator so this is what I get
right that's the log 1 minus this guy
which is equal to minus log 1 plus e to
the theta ok so I'm going a bit fast but
these are very elementary manipulations
maybe requires one more line to convince
yourself but just do it in the comfort
of your room and then what you have is
the exponential of Y times theta and
then I have minus log 1 plus e theta ok
so this is the representation of the PMF
of a Bernoulli distribution as part of a
member of the canonical exponential
family and it tells me that B of theta
is equal to log 1 plus e of theta that's
what I have there from there I can
compute the expectation which you know
hopefully I'm gonna get P as the mean
and P times 1 minus P as the variance
otherwise that would be weird so let's
just do this B prime of theta should
give me the mean and indeed B prime of
theta is e to the theta divided by 1
plus e to the theta which is exactly the
speed that I had there okay just for fun
let's well I don't know maybe that's not
part of it yeah let's not compute the
second derivative that's probably gonna
be on your homework at some point
if not on the final all right so be
prime now we know how I erased it of
course G the canonical link is B prime
inverse and I claim that this is gonna
give me the logit function log of mu
over 1 minus mu so let's check that so B
prime is this thing so now I want to
find the inverse well I should really
call my inverse a function of P and I've
done it before right all I have to do is
to solve this equation which I've
actually just done it that's where I'm
actually coming from so it's actually
telling me that the solution of this
thing is equal to log of P over 1 minus
P ok we just solve this thing both ways
and this is indeed log it of P by
definition of log it so B prime inverse
dysfunction that seemed to come out of
nowhere is really just the inverse of D
prime which we know is the canonical
link and canonical is some sort of ad
hoc choices that we've made by saying
let's just take the link such that D of
MU is giving me the actual canonical
parameter theta yeah yeah you're right
now of course I'm going through all this
trouble but you could see it immediately
I know this is gonna be Stata we also
have prior knowledge hopefully that the
expectation of a Bernal is P itself so
right at this step when I say that I'm
gonna take theta to be this guy I
already knew that the canonical link was
the legate link because I just said oh
here's theta and it's just this function
of meu bem okay so you can do that for a
bunch of examples and this is what
they're gonna give you so in the
Gaussian case B of theta we've actually
computed it actually once this is theta
square over 2 so the derivative of this
thing is really just theta which means
that G or G inverse is actually equal to
the identity okay and again sort of you
know sanity check when I'm in the
gaussian case there's nothing general
about general linear models they don't
have a link the poor some case you can
actually check did we do this actually
yes we did it right so that's when we
had this a of theta and so B is e of
theta which means that the natural link
is the inverse which is log which is the
inverse of exponential and so that's the
great logarithm link which as I said you
know I use the word natural that you can
also use the work in article if you want
to describe this function as being the
right function to map the positive real
line to the entire real line the birnley
we just did it so be the cumulative
cumulant is log of 1 plus e of theta
which is log of mu over 1 minus mu and
and gamma function where you have the
thing you're gonna see is log a minus
log of minus venta you've seen this this
the reciprocal link is the link that
actually shows up so minus 1 over mu
okay that map's this is another link
sorry this is
okay yeah okay that's the one okay so
are there any questions about canonical
links canonical families
I used the word canonical a lot but is
everything fitting together right now
right so we have this function we have a
canonical exponential family by
assumption it has a function B which
contains every information we want we
just at the beginning of the lecture we
establish that it has information about
the mean in the first derivative about
the variance in the second derivative
and it's also giving us a canonical link
all right so just cherish this B once
you've found it because it's everything
you need yeah I don't know political
preference you know I don't know
honestly if I were you know serious
practitioner I probably would have a
better answer for you at this point I
just don't I think it's a matter of
practice and and and actual preferences
you can also try both you we didn't
mention the do there's this idea of
cross validation well we mentioned it
without going too much detail but you
know you could try both and see which
one performs best on a yet and sin
dataset in terms of prediction and just
say I prefer this one of the two because
this actually comes as part of your
modeling assumption right you modelled
not only did you decide to model the
image of Mew through the link function
as a linear model but you're really
really what you're saying right your
model is saying law so you have two
pieces of neural the distribution of Y
but you also have the fact that mu is
modeled as G inverse of X transpose beta
and for different G's this is just
different modeling assumptions right so
you know why should this be be linear
this thing would be linear I don't know
my my you know my authority as a person
who's not examined the thousand data
sets for both things would be that the
changes are fairly minor
okay so this was all for one observation
we just you know basically did
probability might we describe some
density some properties of the densities
how to compute expectation that was
really just probability it was no data
involved at any point we did a bit of
modeling but it was all from one
observation what we're gonna try to do
now is given do the you know the reverse
engineering to probability that is
statistics given data what can I infer
by my model now remember there's three
parameters that are sort of floating
around in this model right there one
that was theta there one that was mu and
there were one that is beta okay so
those are the three parameters that are
floating around what we wanted to say
what we said is that the expectation of
Y given X is mu of X okay so if I ask
them it new I know the conditional
expectation of Y given X which
definitely gives me theta of X right how
do I go from U of X to theta of X yeah
the inverse of wood of the arrow yeah
sure but how do i how do I go from this
guy to this guy so theta as a function
of new ways yeah right so we just
computed that mu was B prime of theta so
it means that theta is just V prime
inverse of MU okay so those two things
are the same as far as we're concerned
because we know that B prime is strictly
increasing it's invertible so it's just
a matter of repr motorization and we
just can switch from one to the other
whenever we want but why we go through
mu because you know so far for the
entire semester I told you there's one
parameter that Stata does not have to be
the mean and that's the parameter that
we care about is the one on which we
want to do interference that's the one
for which we're gonna compute the Fisher
information
this was the parameter that was zero our
object of worship and now I'm saying oh
I'm gonna have mu that like coming
around and why we have nu is because
this is the MU that we use to go to beta
all right so I can go freely from the
prime to from theta to MU using V prime
or V prime inverse and now I can go from
new to beta because I have the G of MU
of X is beta transpose X okay so in the
end now this is gonna be my object of
worship this is gonna be the parameter
that matters because once I set beta I
set everything else through this chain
so the question is if I start stacking
up this pile of parameters right so I
start with my beta which in turns give
me mu which in terms gives me of theta
can I just have like a long stream lined
can i what what is the outcome when I
actually start writing my likelihood not
as a function of theta not as a function
of MU but as a function of beta which is
the one at the end of the chain okay and
hopefully things are gonna happen nicely
and they might not yeah G is G that's my
link right G of mu of X now it's mu is a
function of X
because it's conditional on X okay so
this is really theta of X mu of X but B
is not a function of X because it's just
it's just something that tells me what
the function of X is new is the
conditional expectation of Y given X it
has actually a fancy name in the
statistic literature
it's called anybody knows the name of
this function U of X which is the
conditional expectation of Y given X
that's the regression function that's
actual definition if I tell you what is
the definition of the regression
function that's just the conditional
expectation of Y given X and we're just
you know I could look at any property of
the conditional distribution of Y given
X I could look at the conditional 95th
percentile I can look at the conditional
median I could look at the conditional
interquartile range can look at the
conditional variance but I decided to
look at the conditional expectation
which is called the regression function
okay yes oh there's no transpose here
actually only Victoria manual uses prime
for transpose and I found it confusing
with the derivatives so Prime's here is
only a derivative oh yeah sorry beta
transpose X aureus I used okay so you
said what I said that G of mu of X is
beta transpose X
isn't that the same thing those X is a
vector here right so X transpose beta
and beta transpose X are the same thing
right so beta is looks like this extra
looks like this it's just a simple
number simple number yeah you're right
when I start to look at matrices I'm
gonna have to be slightly more careful
when I do this okay so let's do the
reverse engineering I'm giving you data
from this data hopefully you should be
able to get what the conditional if I
give you an infinite amount of data you
would know exactly what the of pairs X Y
you would know exactly what the
conditional distribution of Y given X is
and in particular you would know what
the conditional expectation of Y given X
is which means that you would know mu
which means that you would know theta
which means they would know beta okay
now when I have a finite number of
observations I'm gonna try to estimate
mu of X but really I'm gonna you go the
other way around because the fact that I
assume specifically that new of X is of
the form G of MU of X is X transpose
beta then that means that I only have to
estimate beta which is a much simpler
object that the entire regression
function okay and so that's what I'm
gonna go for I'm gonna try to represent
the likelihood the log likelihood my
data as a function not of theta not of
mu but of beta and then maximize that
guy all right so now rather than
thinking of just one observation I'm
gonna have a bunch of observations and
every time you see here so this might
actually look a little confusing but
let's just make sure that we understand
each other before we go any further so
I'm gonna have observations x1 y1 all
the way to X and Y and just like in a
natural regression problem except that
here my Y's might be zero one valued
they might be positive value they might
be exponential they might be anything in
the canonical exponential family and
okay so I have this I have this thing
and now what I have is that
so my observations are x1 y1 xn yn and
what I want is that I'm going to talk
about I'm going to assume that the
conditional expectation of Y I given x
sorry yeah the conditional the
conditional distribution of Y given X I
is something that has density I'm not
gonna jump at the Phi in the C now and
what why do I have theta I and theta is
because theta I is really a function of
the of X I right so it's really theta I
of X I but what do I know about theta I
of X I it's actually equal to B I did
this error twice B prime inverse of MU
of X I
okay and I also know that this thing is
actually I'm going to assume that this
is of the form beta transpose X I okay
and this is why I have the theta I is
because this theta I is a function of X
I and I'm going to assume a very simple
form from this thing sorry sorry sorry
sorry that's yeah sorry I should not
write it like this this is only when I
have the canonical link so this is
actually equal to B prime inverse of G
of X I transpose beta and when I have
the canonical link sorry G inverse those
two things are actually cancelling each
other okay so as before I'm gonna stack
everything into some well actually I'm
not gonna stack anything for the moment
I'm just gonna give you a peek at what's
happening next week rather than just
manipulating the data all right so here
is how we're gonna proceed at this point
well now I'm going to want to write my
likelihood function not as a function of
theta but as a function of beta because
that's the parameter I'm actually trying
to maximize right so if I have a link so
this thing that matters here I'm gonna
call H by definition this is gonna be H
of X I transposed beta
Hellena you have a question okay so
right so this is just all the things
that we know right theta is just the by
definition of the fact that mu is B
prime of theta the mean is B prime of
theta it means that theta is B prime
inverse of mu and then mu is modeled
from the systematic component G of MU is
X I transpose beta so this is G inverse
of X I transpose beta so I'm gonna have
D prime inverse of G prime of G inverse
this function is a bit annoying to say
so I'm just gonna call it H and when I
do the composition of 2 inverse is the
inverse of the composition of those two
things in the reverse order so
H is really the inverse of G composed
with B prime G of B prime inverse okay
and now if I have the canonical link
since I know that G is B prime inverse
this is really just the identity so as
you can imagine this entire thing which
is actually quite complicated we just
say oh this thing actually does not show
up when I have the canonical link I
really just have that theta I can be
replaced by X I of beta so think about
going back to this guy here now beta
theta becomes only X I transpose beta
that's going to be much more simple
simple to optimize because remember when
I'm gonna do log likelihood this thing
is gonna go away I'm gonna sum those
guys and so what I'm gonna have is
something which is essentially linear in
beta and then I'm gonna have this minus
B which is just minus the sum of convex
functions of beta and so I'm gonna have
to bring in the tools of convex
optimization now it's not just gonna be
take the gradient set it to zero there's
gonna be more complicated to do that I'm
gonna have to do that in that iterative
fashion and so that's what I'm telling
you when you look at your log likelihood
for all those functions you sum the
exponential goes away because you had
the log and then you have all these
things here I kept the B I kept the H
but if H is the identity this is the
linear function the linear part Y I
times X I transpose beta minus B of my
theta which is now only X I transpose
beta and that's the function I want to
maximize in beta okay that's just simple
I mean it's a convex function when I
know what B is I have an explicit
formula formula for this and I want to
just bring in some optimization and
that's what we're gonna do and we're
gonna see three different methods which
are really basically the same method
it's something which is based on it's
just a adaptation or specialization of
the so called newton-raphson method
which is essentially telling you do
iterative local quadratic approximation
to your function so second-order Taylor
expansion minimize this guy and then do
it again from where you were okay and
we'll see that this can be actually
implemented using what's called
iteratively re-weighted least words
which means that every step since it's
just a quadratic there's gonna be just
squares
there every step can actually be solved
by using a weighted least squares
version of the problem okay
so I'm gonna stop here for today so
we'll continue and probably not finish
this chapter but finished next week and
and then I think there's only one
lecture actually for the last lecture
what do you guys want to do do you want
to have donuts insider do you wanna do
you want to just have like some more
like out looking lecture on you know
what's happening post 1975 in statistics
do you want to have a review for the
final exam pragmatic people all right
you want to do interesting advanced for
the last lecture
yeah so that's sort of yeah the thing is
I think so this there's true that that's
basically what I'm asking right the
interesting events topics versus let's
like ask me any question you want those
questions can be about interesting
advanced topics though like what are
interesting advanced topics I'm sorry
yeah yeah we can always do the but
Donuts all right all right